let's say we have the repeating decimal
zero point four zero zero eight where
the digits four zero zero eight keep on
repeating so if we were to write it out
it would look something like this zero
point four zero zero eight four zero
zero eight four zero zero eight and
keeps on going forever what I want you
to do right now is pause the video and
think about whether you can represent
this repeating decimal as an infinite
sum as an infinite series and then think
about whether that infinite series is a
geometric series so I'm assuming you've
given a go at it so let's think about it
so for each term of my infinite series
I'm going to represent one of these
repeating patterns of four zero zero
eight so for example I will make this
four zero zero eight my first term so
this could be viewed as zero and these
this four zero zero eight represents
zero point four zero zero eight then I
could make this for zero zero eight my
next term or my next term will represent
this for zero zero eight and that means
its zero and this for zero zero eight is
the same thing as zero point zero zero
zero zero four zero zero eight and then
this next for zero zero eight
well that represents zero point and we
have eight zeros one two three four five
six seven eight four zero zero eight
four zero zero eight and then we would
just keep on going like that forever so
we're just going to keep on going like
that forever so hopefully this this is
there's a pattern here we're essentially
throwing four zeros before the decimal
every time and and we could just keep on
going like that forever so this is an
infinite sum it's an infinite series the
next question is is is this a geometric
series well in order for it to be a
geometric series to go from one term to
the next you must be multiplying by the
same value by the same common ratio so
what are we multiplying when we go from
zero point four zero zero eight to this
one right over here where we add four
zeros before the four zero zero eight
what are we multiplying well we move the
decimal four spots to the left so we're
multiplying by
to the negative 4th or you could view it
as we're multiplying by 0.001 absolute
or one more 0 0 1 10 to the negative 1 2
3 4 to go from here to here well same
thing move the decimal 4 places to the
left so once again we're multiplying by
0.0001 and so it looks pretty clear that
we have a common ratio of 10 to the
negative 4th power so we can rewrite we
can rewrite all of this business as zero
point 4 0 0 8 times our common ratio for
this first term times our common ratio
of 10 to the negative fourth to the 0th
power so that's that gives us that right
over there plus zero point 4 0 0 8 times
10 to the negative fourth to the first
power and that gives us that value right
over there plus zero point 4 0 0 8 times
10 to the negative 4 to the second power
and we keep on going and so in this form
it looks a little bit clearer like a
geometric series an infinite geometric
series and if we wanted to write that
out with Sigma notation we could write
this as the sum from k equals 0 to
infinity to infinity of well what's our
first term going to be it's going to be
zero point four zero or zero point four
zero zero eight times times our common
ratio which we could write out as either
10 to the negative fourth or 0.0001 I'll
try it as 10 to the negative fourth 10
to the negative fourth to the K power to
the K power so the next interesting
question we've now this is clearly can
be represented as a geometric series is
well what is this sum you know you might
say well that's just going to be four
zero zero eight repeating over and over
but I want to express it as a fraction
and so I want you to pause this video
use what you already know about try
finding the sum of an infinite geometric
series to try to express this thing
right over here as a fraction so I'm
assuming you've had a go at it so let's
think about
we've already seen we've already derived
in previous videos that the sum of an
infinite geometric series let me do this
in a neutral color if I have a series
like this K equals zero to infinity of a
R to the K power that this sum is going
to be equal to a over 1 minus R we've
derived this actually in several other
videos so in this case this is going to
be well our a here is zero point four
zero zero eight and it's going to be
that over 1 1 minus our common ratio
- and I'll write it like this zero point
zero zero zero one one ten-thousandth so
what's this going to be well this is
going to be the same thing as zero point
four zero zero eight if you if you take
one minus one ten-thousandth or you
could use this ten thousand ten
thousandth minus one ten thousandth
you're going to have you're going to
have 9999 over or 9,999 10,000 ten
thousands
once again you could view let me write
this out just so this doesn't look
confusing one is the same thing as ten
thousand over ten thousand and you're
subtracting one over ten thousand and so
you're going to get 9999 over ten
thousand and so this is going to be the
same thing this is going to be the same
thing as zero point four zero zero eight
times ten thousand so times ten thousand
over nine thousand nine hundred and
ninety nine well what's this top number
times ten thousand well that's just
going to give us four thousand and eight
four thousand and eight over nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine nine
thousand nine hundred
9 and we've just expressed that
repeating decimal as a fraction so we
have succeeded and you might say well
maybe we can simplify this thing and so
let's see what if we can if this is
already a fraction so we've already kind
of achieved it but if we want to get a
little bit simpler see if we add the
digits up here 4 plus 8 is 12 so in 1
plus 2 is 3 so this up here is divisible
by 3 and this down here is clearly
divisible by 3 so let's divide both of
them by 3 so 3 goes into 4008 let's see
it goes into 4 one time subtract you get
a 10 3 times 3 is 9 subtract yet another
10 goes into 3 times 3 times 3 is 9
subtract bring down an 8 3 goes into 18
exactly 6 times so our numerator is 1336
this is no longer divisible by 3 the sum
of the digits is not divisible by 3 is
not a multiple of 3 and if you divide
this bottom number by 3 you get 3333 and
I think we have simplified it I think we
have simplified it about as well as we
can although I might well we could check
more let me know if I didn't but either
way we have now written this this was
pretty neat we saw that a repeating
decimal can be represented not just as
an infinite series but as an infinite
geometric series and then we were able
to use the formula that we derived for
the sum of an infinite geometric series
to actually express it as a fraction